as soon as we continue our discussion on
all-new all-different marvel and DC
rebirth something I want to point out
here is in my video on Green Lantern's I
talked about a schedule that we were
going to be using is something I also
want to point out here is that schedule
something were going to be using here in
a little bit but for right now we have a
lot of catching up to do on both DC
rebirth and all-new all-different marvel
especially considering that Marvel now
2.0 is right around the corner and so
what I'm gonna do and I'm gonna watch
the analytics see how you guys respond
to it but what I'm going to do is
basically bombard you guys with all-new
all-different marvel and DC we birth
stuff now it's only gonna be two videos
a day I'm not going to upload like five
or six videos a day but we're gonna go
through all the early set all the
characters that I like the teams that I
like the first story arcs for DC rebirth
and we're gonna do the same thing for
Marvel Comics and that way we can be
prepped for when we get through like you
know the first three arc of the
champions when we get into u.s. Avengers
we get into the New Avengers that takes
the place of all-new all-different
Avengers when we start getting into that
stuff well basically kind of just be
able to go forward as opposed to having
to play catch-up you know at that point
in time but what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna pick up with all-new
all-different amazing spider-man I dead
no more now dance lon actually does a
pretty interesting job with this story
this is kind of cool to me because a lot
of the stories that I've read so far you
know the story arcs you know power play
different things like that with with
all-new all-different marvel the
spider-man series hasn't resonated
extremely well just because a lot of it
felt like lead-up to something else it
felt like pre lude and it was a lot of
stuff happening but nothing happening at
the same time and what this does is a
sort of begins to turn things on their
head in a couple of different ways the
first is that it initially picks up with
Jay jonah Jameson senior now for those
of you guys who don't know a lot of this
stuff ties into dance lots run a little
bit before his run but uh the idea is
that Jay jonah Jameson senior is starkly
different from his son Jay jonah Jameson
jr. who of course is the head honcho for
the Daily Bugle and the one that writes
all those articles about spider-man now
unlike his son Jay Joe and Jameson
senior does not share a hatred for
spider-man he actually adore spider-man
but more so than that he found himself
in a relationship with Aunt May and so
let's present a kind of a weird scenario
for Jay jonah Jameson but the fact
remains that they deal with it the best
they can the issue here and what Dan
Slott doesn't really tell us is that Jay
jonah Jameson senior is suffering from
some illness we don't really
know what it is but it's basically
progressed to the point where it's
confining jay jonah jameson senior to
Abed and so the idea here or at least
what Dan Slott seems to be doing is
toying around with the notion that Jay
jonah Jameson senior may die now this in
and of itself is not huge what this
actually does is set the stage for
things that progress later on but what
we end up doing here is we basically
pick up with Peter Parker while he's on
route to a destination and he's toying
or looking at the idea of people who are
cloning people who are being cloned by a
corporation called new you now new you
is something new by Dan Slott that he's
created recently and it centers around
the jackal and we'll actually get to him
here in a minute but for Peter Parker
with the analysis of these organs that
he's seeing they're genetically
identical to their originals all the
illnesses are basically eliminated
meaning that if somebody had you know an
illness that would kill them and you
were to clone a heart that they need or
you were to clone a liver that they need
all the genetic problems that they face
would be eliminated in their entirety
you know and so the idea here is is
basically Dan Slott kind of setting at
the stage that cloning would most likely
be the route that was used to save J
John Jameson senior but again he doesn't
tell us that directly he just kind of
leads us on our own imagination to
believe that that will most likely be
the case not from here
we pick up with the jackal and we start
to get into this explanation now
something I want to point out is that I
talked to Joel over a cape Joel when I
was trying to grab my bearings on this
because there were a few things that I'd
missed from previous story arcs that
didn't quite fit in or didn't quite a
you know that caused us to kind of not
make sense to me
and one of the things we had talked
about was the jackal and this is just
kind of a general discussion between the
two of us but the jackal as he's
presented here miles Warren is different
from a jackal that we saw you know
before secret wars in the sense that
that version of jackal was sadistic was
cruel like to inflict harm on people but
this version of jackal isn't that way
and because everything else seems to be
the same from before secret Wars and
he's really the only major difference
here Joel hypothesized that there's only
one of two circumstances going on either
something happened in the life of miles
warrant that changed his entire outlook
on life or this is not the jackal this
is not miles Warren instead this is you
know Ben Riley or it's Kane it's one of
the clones from the clone the original
clone saga of the spider-man story now
again I'm not swearing this is absolute
and I doubt Joel would swear to it as
absolute but I wouldn't be surprised if
Joel had a video on this at some point
in time and so you should probably look
up cape Joel on YouTube you'll find his
link down in the description
head over there and check it out because
it's actually a pretty cool theory that
he had but the fact remains here
they're basically emphasizing focus on
max Dylan on electro now this goes on
before Secret Wars and this is why I say
not everything an all-new all-different
marvel is all new and all different but
it doesn't mean that it's bad now prior
to Secret Wars electro had basically
been part of the superior six which is
like a more updated version of the
original sinister six under Doctor
Octopus and this high Dan as part of
superior spider-man when Doctor Octopus
took over the body of Peter Parker and
so superior 6 was just kind of
capitalizing on the title superior
spider-man but the fact remains here
that electro despite his abilities had
always sort of been a street-level
criminal he had never really done
anything global anything massive except
for one time and that was during Brian
Michael Bendis run of New Avengers when
electro had been contracted to basically
take out the power to the raft to a
superpower prison and allow all those
those supervillains to escape what
enough happening though is that because
electro kind of fell back into the realm
of being a street villain nothing ever
really came of it and so during superior
six he was more or less placed under the
control of Doctor Octopus and one
superior six came to an end and those
various villains went their separate
ways
electro kind of became the butt of jokes
people made fun of him people didn't
take him seriously and so the idea was
for him to basically prove his worth by
going back to the raft and causing
another blackout and freeing all those
super villains again the issue here was
that his powers ran into a state of
instability and what this did is it
caused him to kill a woman that was in
love with him named Francine Frey now
Francine fry was kind of like a like a
groupie so to speak for for supervillain
she loved the idea of supervillains she
was both you know emotionally and
romantically attracted to them and so
for her match Dylan was a guy that she
could latch on to and while they did
form as close to the relationship as you
know two villains can get the fact
remains that because his powers were
unstable he had accidentally killed her
now eventually this led into Peter
Parker developing technology to
basically take away the powers of
supervillains as opposed to putting them
in prisons and the system that Peter
Parker had developed was destroyed but
the first person to be exposed to it was
Elektra which is the reason why in
store erupted this point electro has had
no powers and so for those of you guys
who were curious as to why he's been
powerless this is the reason why now the
entire goal of The Jackal here is to
basically bring back the powers of Max
Dillon or at least it seems to be that
way to basically reinvigorate his powers
but more so than that because max Dillon
is hesitant because he doesn't really
want to undergo this experiment he's
shown
Francine Frey basically Francine Frey
was cloned and brought back now Dan
Slott shows the abilities of Jackyl in a
couple ways because Jack was cloning
people we know by virtue of what we
talked about a minute ago with Peter
Parker that any genetic impurities that
they had have been wiped away that any
illnesses any genetic imperfections that
have been they've been completely
eliminated so Francine Frey is in pique
100% perfect health the other half of
this is a Francine Frey had a lot of
tattoos she had a lot of piercings and
those have been removed and so it's
almost like a purified version so to
speak of her original self now where Dan
Slott chooses to go with this is
something that I'm not entirely sure of
it may result in Peter Parker being
completely d powered at some point in
the future during clone conspiracy we're
just kind of spitballing with this but
the fact remains here that with Francine
Frey being present it's basically the
kind of motivation that jackal uses to
get her to motivate you know electro to
undergo the experiment now with regards
to Peter Parker in this story this is
one of the interesting scenarios because
he's basically kind of like a background
figure here he's not a main character
he's not the main star of this instead a
lot of emphasis is put on jackal which i
think is a great break away from what
we've seen so far granted you know
spider-man stories should always center
around spider-man but it doesn't hurt to
have a story arc here or there that
takes him away from being the forefront
it actually gives us perspectives from
other people and what happens in this is
is basically Dan Slott showing us that
spider-man has a way of picking up who's
been cloned and who hasn't and what
happens is one of his employees is
basically injured in an experiment or
injured in an incident at Parker
industries and Peter Parker basically
calls on his employees to activate new
you or at least to use the organs that
I've been harvested from new you or the
technology they use to basically provide
this employee with the organs he needs
in order to continue living because
during the during the incident his lungs
his heart his liver had been damaged
beyond repair but what happens is when
Peter Parker goes to see him his spider
sense kicks in and Peter Parker realized
is that even if even if you can't detect
that this person's been cloned that
these organs have been brought in from
somebody else and so this guy is
basically tricking out fighter man's
spider-sense now Dan Slott doing this
presents a couple finding situations the
first is that if Peter Parker were to
encounter a regular civilian who's been
used by the jackal but has the organs of
another villain it's going to create a
scenario whereby Peter Parker doesn't
know that they're actually a bad guy and
we're going to see this experiment come
to fruition we're going to see where
this can lead to here in the next little
bit but the next thing that happens here
is we actually end up picking up with
Jay jonah Jameson jr. traveling back to
his home and running into a woman named
Marla now again this is really just a
dance a lot kind of thickening the plot
here you know of course Marla was a
character who had a romantic interest
with Jay jonah jameson the two of them
had the potential to be happy but the
issue was that she had actually died and
so this really sent Jay jonah jameson
down the continued paths of hating
spider-man more so than he had before
but in an event what we end up doing is
we basically jump back to the jackal of
course we have the Prowler Hobie Brown
acting as a Peter Parker
while Mark is acting as spider-man while
Peter Parker is conducting his normal
business what is up happening is Hobie
basically changes out of his Peter
Parker costume out of the spider-man
costume and transitions into the costume
of the Prowler now the reason why he
does this is for couple reasons the
first is because spider-man is known as
a superhero and so spider-man were to go
about some nefarious acts were to be
experimenting around the different
things it could cause problems moreso
than that the Prowler is a street-level
hero me and he doesn't no one really
knows if he has any ties to anyone no
one really takes him seriously and so if
you were to spy on these villains and if
you were to be caught they wouldn't come
after spider-man's friends and family
they would come after prowlers friends
and family but because he has no friends
and family there's really no one that
they would go after they would try to
kill him and if they failed they would
just kind of write it off and so this is
exactly what happens the Prowler breaks
into new you and he begins poking around
trying to figure out were these where
these organs came from who's cloning
them someone and so forth and he
eventually stumbles across the the layer
of jackal any witnesses both jackal as
well as the lizard and a handful of
others engaging in this process to
attempt to restore Max Dylan's powers to
him the problem with this is that when
the when the experiment occurs Knox
does not get his electro powers back
instead the powers go into the suit but
they don't actually go into him and so
he could channel them through the suit
but they're not part of his physical
body anymore and so what happens here is
that while he is trying to cope with
this wallet right he's trying to figure
out what's what's going on suddenly his
powers seem to activate by virtue of
Francine and she begins absorbing his
powers to the point that she absorbs the
life force of max Dylan killing him in
the process and so the result here is
that she effectively becomes the new
electro Francine Frey is now the new
electro and Max Dylan seems to be dead
for all intents and purposes but while
this incident takes place we end up
finding the Prowler is discovered by
lizard and by jackal and you know these
various people now of course jackal says
do not kill him he says you know keep
him alive
the reason being because they could use
him for their own purposes the issue
here is a prowler is easily able to make
his escape and he sought after by
electro or by the new electro Francine
fry but when she tracks him down
she actually kills him now again miles
didn't want her to Jack will wanted
Hobie is stay alive but because of the
fact that he was killed miles basically
brings him back and this is where the
caveat of the clones comes into play
what Miles says or I guess so what he
does is he presents Hobie Brown with the
fact that he's been brought back to life
that he's been cloned and been revived
but the issue is that he's also given a
pill and he's told this pill has to be
taken on a regular basis indicating that
this is how jackal keeps the clones in
check that if they don't take the pill
they'll presumably die and so because
they want to live they'll do whatever
they need to do in order to stay alive
and so what we do here is we basically
skip forward a bit and we end up picking
up with a backup feature now this backup
feature actually centers around the
notion of how it is that miles worn how
the jackal is able to cover all these
things with the fact that he's also
incurring the wrath of different enemies
along the way now again this is kind of
a prequel this little segment we're
going to talk about here is kind of a
prequel to the events that we've talked
about so far but what happened is jackal
had basically approached kingpin and he
told kingpin that he would bring his
wife Vanessa back if kingpin was willing
to fund his his escapades fund his
desire to clone various people for his
own personal reasons but this was a
funny thing because again myself and
Joel were talking about this and when
kingpin meets his wife where almost
everybody else would be excited to see
their loved ones come back from the dead
is that the kingpin brakes Vanessa's
neck and says that's not my wife you
know this is an abomination not only
that he says that because of the fact
that Jackyl would dare to clone Vanessa
that he's defiled her memory and that
jackal has earned an enemy in the form
of kingpin now was also cool about this
is that because the jackal has been
cloning people he effectively has those
clones at his disposal and the result is
that he calls in Rhino now of course
with Rhino superior strength he's easily
able to take on kingpin and of course
for the two of them fighting one another
we actually pick up with spider-man
joining the fray now where spider-man's
able to hold him off where spider-man is
able to to basically send Rhino running
to remove him from the situation the
fact remains a kingpin survived and
kingpin makes his escape but what he
says is that his main focus here is
jackal a jackal created the most
offensive instance of you know angering
kingpin by cloning his wife into filing
her memory I guess cloning his dead wife
and defiling her memory so his goal is
to basically track down jackal but if
for whatever reason kingpin dies in the
process he'll have fighter man do his
bidding for him now from here this is
really just kind of Dan Slott tying up
loose ends you know sort of giving us an
instance of what direction things may go
in of the idea of this clone conspiracy
story that's coming up and so the thing
about this this segment of the story is
kind of an epilogue but again this just
basically deals with the idea that there
are various people out there who are
being cloned by the jackal of course we
know that when Stacy the original gwen
stacy had been brought back to life by
jackal and that was part of marvel's
free comic book day for those of you
guys who were curious when the when dead
no more was originally announced you'll
probably have noticed and we talked
about it on the weekly poll a lot of
people were saying went out when Stacy's
gonna come back to life when Stacy's
going to be the new love interest of
Peter Parker due to the fact that Mary
Jane's kind of been ushered out and
she's with Tony Stark and this really
seems to be the case it looks like Dan
Slott kind of setting the stage for a
return to the status quo before the
before the Mary Jane Watson era with
when Stacy being the the love interest
of Peter Parker now whether he actually
does this is something that we'll have
to wait and see but for right now it's
just kind of a tour of everything that's
going on we of course see Mae Parker's I
guess made Jameson now Aunt May spending
time with Jay Joe
Jamison senior Peter Parker except in
the fact that some individuals may die
but by virtue of the knowledge that he
has with regards to those cloned organs
that is possible to bring them back to
life or at the very least keep them
alive a kind of wings on his mind but we
also see Peter Parker dealing with this
idea that because a person was cloned or
because the the life of his employee was
saved that he recognized him as a
potential threat even though he didn't
seem to be a threat and so as as begins
to sort of wrap up it looks as though
Jay jonah Jameson senior may end up
dying but in the end we don't really
know what direction this will go in
until we officially pick up with ecoan
sagas story but again this is one of the
reasons why if those of you guys who
were curious this is one of the reasons
why a lot of people are basically making
the case that it seems as though Dan
Slott is kind of retelling this original
cone saga story that Dan Slott is going
back to the roots of spider-man clones
of Peter Parker clones basically and so
again as this story comes to an end we
basically come to the realization of the
fact that Jay jonah Jameson senior has
died and so it seems as if the idea that
if clones are going to start taking over
this will most likely be a byproduct of
something the Peter Parker has done
himself that in his effort to to grant
his aunt may the happiness she deserves
that he's going to go about and clone
Jay jonah Jameson senior which will in
turn lead to a whole plethora of
problems in and of themselves but with
that being said if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like make
sure you hit the sub button become part
of the rob4 and leave a comment let me
know what you guys think about this so
far because in truth you know again I
was a little hesitant about the
spider-man stories up to this point but
I'm actually not really hesitant anymore
Dan Slott seems to be doing a pretty
good job with the with this particular
story I really like what he's doing so
far but again you know I'm just kind of
throwing my thoughts out here so let me
know what you guys think
now we'll catch you guys on peace
you
[Music]